sabias que aproximadamente el 15 por
ciento de la población del mundo tiene
alguna discapacidad
sabías que esa cifra coincide con la de
uruguay
eso significa que estadísticamente cada
100 personas que conozcas deberías
conocer a 15 con alguna discapacidad te
invito a que pienses un momento en si
esto es así
no lo es o te resulta difícil
identificar 15 personas con discapacidad
que conozcas quizás sea porque no
tenemos una sociedad tan inclusiva y
accesible sigamos pensando piensa en un
lugar cualquiera que frecuente es mucho
lo tienes ahora piensa podría una
persona con cualquier discapacidad
acceder y moverse en ese espacio
probablemente en tu respuesta sea no es
muy interesante cuando pensamos en ellos
donde están las personas con
discapacidad se crea con una división
invisible pero bien presente entre los
que pudieron acceder a ese lugar
formando parte y los que quedaron por
fuera también es interesante y pensar
cuántas veces nos quedamos por fuera de
algo por no saber por no preguntar y en
muchos muchos casos por no poder
derribar esa barrera que alguien más uso
o me van a decir que nunca les paso me
van a decir que todos lean rápidamente
el cartel del autobús o solo me pasa a
mí que tengo que esperar a que frene en
la garita para poder leerlo a ninguno le
paso de no llegar al soporte de agarre
del autobús
ninguno de ustedes tuvo que pedir ayuda
para leer un folleto porque la letra es
pequeña
es extraño pensar en que algunas están
dentro de los que pueden y otros quedan
por fuera
se siente raro no
[Música]
ahora les voy a invitar a que se relajen
se retraigan un poco y recuerden hay un
momento donde ustedes se quedaron afuera
recuerden la situación el lugar el olor
que había en ese lugar como estaban
vestidos quienes estaban con ustedes
ya lo tienen bueno ahora los invito a
que piensen que sintieron y cómo se
sintieron
imaginen que el 90% de sus días
estuvieran compuestos por situaciones de
ese tipo
algunos de ustedes tienen hijos o hijas
chicos han podido leer un libro
últimamente muchas personas dicen que
hay una sola forma de leer un libro yo
pienso que hay muchas de hecho yo soy de
los que tienen hijos chicos soy padre de
juan martín que tiene cuatro años los
cumplía hace poco y me toca cocinar y
saben que mientras cocino leo libros
ustedes se preguntarán como con lectores
de pantalla que se encargan de traducir
el texto en voz algunos opinan que estos
sistemas son solo para personas que no
pueden ver o tienen baja visión yo creo
que son para quien los necesite como las
rampas algunos de ustedes nunca subió
por las rampas sin usar sillas ruedas
las rampas fueron creadas
para las personas que se la sal en silla
de ruedas y sin embargo para una persona
de avanzada edad son excelentes también
pensar en un diseño más universal en
libros en edificios en cursos con
herramientas para que todos y todas
podamos usarla es fundamental en el
siglo 21 las nuevas tecnologías nos
permiten grabar vídeos audios textos
hacer traducciones con gran facilidad e
imprimir en nuestros hogares saben
cuánto cuesta hacer carteles con
pictogramas el extra grande y
monocromático mucho menos que las
cartelerías que solemos ver llenas de
colores tipo de letras super complejas
que muchas veces impiden su rápida
comprensión y en varios casos
directamente su lectura ahora tengo otra
pregunta para ustedes si no sé hoy viene
con muchas preguntas
y cuántos de ustedes miran netflix
estadísticamente hay casi 140 millones
de suscriptores en el mundo muchos
verdad han probado disfrutar de una
película con audiodescripción es ver
otra película es lograr comprender todo
y no perderse ningún detalle y pensar
que fue creado para personas con baja
visión o ciegas les voy a compartir uno
de mis gustos a mí me encantan las
películas de suspenso y terror
muchas veces no entendía alguna de sus
escenas
ahora que uso la audiodescripción puedo
puedo captar todo y comprender mejor si
una puerta se abre y rechina sé que es
por algo eso es un ejemplo de diseño
accesible aunque aún falta un intérprete
de lengua de señas pero es una buena
aproximación
tengo una pregunta más tiene ni idea
cuántos mensajes de texto mandaron hoy
ya sea por whatsapp u otro medio seguro
que fueron muchos según las estadísticas
más de 1200 mensajes al día si
escucharon bien más de 1200 mensajes al
día realmente es una herramienta
fantástica y saben que fue pensada para
las personas sordas o con baja audición
y si bien los ascensores no fueron
creados específicamente para personas
con discapacidad física que se desplacen
en silla de ruedas es sus medios para
subir a otros pisos en un edificio y los
que pueden caminar usamos las escaleras
yo nunca lo hago eso es otro ejemplo de
diseño universal que sirven para todos y
todas
en uruguay estamos trabajando la
discapacidad desde los derechos humanos
con esta visión muchas organizaciones
como la somos sociedad de maestros
especializados del uruguay se encuentran
sumando esfuerzos para contribuir a
estos diseños universales para que todos
y todas podamos ejercer nuestros
derechos como seres humanos ejemplo de
eso son los instrumentos impresos en 3-d
para sostener lápiz pensado en una
persona con algún parálisis en la mano
adaptación de computadora con rampas
digitales entre otros y esta visión no
es sólo de grandes organizaciones sino
de todos y todas y esa es la idea que
quiero transmitirles que podamos pensar
como desde nuestros lugares habituales
ya sea de trabajo de estudio o de tiempo
de ocio podemos contribuir a una
sociedad que nos permita hacerlo más
autónomos posibles y amigables con todos
y todas sin barreras de ningún tipo
ustedes pensarán que se necesita mucho
pero en realidad se necesita lo que yo
llamo la mirada inclusiva y luego
informarse pero eso está en google y no
pensemos en grandes acciones aunque
todos saben que no me asusta pensar en
grande pensemos en cosas concretas por
ejemplo la cartelería de los negocios
que sea con letras con un estilo más
simple sin ser ifa con un tamaño más
grande monocromático si es posible con
braille lo cual aprovecha recomendables
es muy lindo aprender braille agregar
pictogramas pensar en realizar las cosas
en varios formatos en textos en audio en
vídeo la disposición de los productos en
las góndolas de supermercado ni contra
el piso ni a dos metros de altura pues
las personas de baja estatura o en silla
de ruedas no podrían alcanzar los
productos en los altos y personas que no
pueden agacharse bolt silla de ruedas
les impida llegar a los productos de más
abajo
tener una caja rápida no solo pensando
la cantidad de productos sino también
para personas que su situación le impida
estar mucho tiempo parada o soportar
gran tiempo de espera por la calle
cuando vemos a una persona ciega por
ejemplo preguntarle si necesita guía es
muy importante preguntar muchas veces no
actuamos por desconocimiento pero si
preguntamos esa persona nos dirá si
necesita algo y en ese caso qué y cómo
juntar los excrementos de nuestras
mascotas en la calle no saliva tirar
chicles y ustedes se preguntarán qué
tiene que ver esto con las personas con
discapacidad pues para una persona en
silla de ruedas
todos estos desechos terminan pasando
por sus manos
ya es hora de dejar de pensar en algunos
y comenzar a pensar en todos y todas es
hora que en el siglo 21 nadie se quede
afuera